hi everyone its Farah from the
intelligence squared team here I'm the
producer of tonight's event and as Chris
said we'd love to hear from you we'd
love to hear your questions if you want
to send us a question please click the
ask a question button on the bottom
left-hand corner of your screen type a
question out and send it to us if you'd
like to direct it to a particular
panelist just write the panelists name
at the beginning of the question during
the event you'll also be able to see how
many questions have been answered and
what questions we've already answered
click to the total answered question
button on the bottom left hand side of
your screen you can expand it and scroll
through the questions that our panelists
have already answered as Chris mentioned
please do tweet at us our hashtag is iq2
and our twitter is at intelligence too
there's also a live chat button which
you can use to chat to your fellow
audience members and tell us what you
think as you listen to the conversation
this is definitely the ask a question
button ask the question tells us a
question directly the live chat is just
for you to interact with your fellow
audience members now we have a brilliant
panel tonight discussing the issues on
all of our minds coronavirus the
discussion is going to be structured
into three parts the trajectory of the
pandemic can we trust the experts and
the impact on the economy and then of
course we're going to open up to the
floor
so please do start sending your
questions in and be patient with us as
we've already had received so many
already there's over 200 members of the
audience with us tonight and that's
growing every second I can see I can see
the list ticking up I'm gonna hand over
now to our chair for tonight's event dr.
alexander van tulleken he's a doctor and
broadcaster with the Diploma in tropical
medicine a diploma in international
humanitarian assistance and the master's
in public health from Harvard he's
presented numerous science programs for
the BBC and channel 4 you may have seen
his documentary a few days ago for
channel 4 called connect coronavirus how
to isolate yourself welcomes and I'll
hand over to you now and our panel of
speakers thank you so much for on thank
you in
telogen squared well it is lovely to be
back I'm sorry about the tech problems
last week but I think it is possibly
even more useful and valuable for us to
be having this event with all the events
of the last week behind us now I think
even as many as 10 days ago we were a
nation to a certain extent divided
people saying we were overreacting and
other people saying we were under
reacting I think now everyone almost
everyone agrees on the serious
seriousness of the crisis and we have
two fears running alongside one another
illness and the specter of a health
service that may be overwhelmed and the
specter of unemployment and the failure
of the economy and I think our panel
today are extraordinarily well
positioned to answer questions about
that and I hope provide some much-needed
reassurance as in all disasters we the
affected population will do the heavy
lifting even more even more than health
care workers in hospitals and so there
is a huge amount at stake for all of us
we are not just listening to the policy
we are the policy in our behaviors has
the government been following the right
scientific advice on the pandemic why
despite the World Health Organization's
pleas to all countries to test test test
have we not been doing very much testing
should the state be rationing food
supplies to make sure there is enough
for all how much prosperity should we be
asked to make to lose in order to save
thousands of lives what is the cost of
saving a life in this pandemic well I
hope we will have some reassuring
answers as I say let me introduce the
speakers we're very lucky to have
Professor David Heyman if you want a
lengthy and entertaining list of awards
that it is possible to win as a doctor
his Wikipedia page will provide you with
some some lengthy reading he is
professor of infectious disease so I
won't read them all out but he is
professor of infectious disease
epidemiology at the London School of
Hygiene and Tropical Medicine he's head
of the center of global health security
at Chatham House formerly chairman of
public health England and former
assistant director-general for health
and security in the environment at the
World Health Organization and he headed
the global response to SARS
and I think we yeah it will be exciting
to get his take on the questions dr.
Barrett
Piang carnea we're very very lucky to
have Barrett with us as well a senior
clinical lecture in public health
medicine at the University of Exeter is
a former senior consultant in
communicable disease communicable
disease control he's worked on influenza
Ebola SARS and tuberculosis he was the
local lead for pandemic influenza
planning at public health England where
he became the reference point for
outbreak planning and previously he has
developed protocols for controlling
tuberculosis outbreaks in schools
hospitals and prisons and finally
professor Linda Yueh economist
broadcaster and writer she is a fellow
in economics as ammendment all the
University of Oxford
she's an adjunct professor at the London
Business School and a visiting professor
at the London School of Economics she's
all the kinds of professor a person can
be her latest book the great economists
how their ideas can help us today was
one of the times business books of the
year and I think it is important to say
beyond all of our lists illustrious
qualifications and accolades and awards
and so on and all of them have
experience and I think a flavor for this
scale of global disaster which is
immensely valuable when we're dealing
with things that are this unknown I'm
David can I start with you um can you
just give us a picture of what your life
has looked like over the last few weeks
what have you been working on one of the
things that have mattered to you what
have you been learning thanks and you
know I'm in a very privileged position
because I chair a group at the World
Health Organization that actually does
the risk assessment of what's going on
today and I think one of the most
interesting and most important things to
know in the world today is that despite
the geopolitical tensions between
countries technical experts from around
the world are working together to
understand this disease and the
understanding has been quite rapid
during the past few months a few weeks
actually but there are still a couple
issues that remain to be completely
understood and that is how transmissible
is this disease between persons how
easily does it go from one person to
another and also we need to better
understand the full clinic
spectrum of disease from the time of
infection to the time of hospitalization
or death so we need to know how many
people are really a symptomatic and how
many people do in fact have mild disease
and then how many have severe disease so
we're learning a lot building your ship
as it sails and I think that the
technical cooperation in the world
that's been sharing so much information
really is an example of how we can work
well together in the 21st century
brilliant David thanks very much for
that about quick sum up and we're gonna
come back to all those questions later I
should emphasize with we we know that so
many people are putting questions in the
D plan is for the first sort of half
hour maybe 20 minutes even for the panel
too I'm gonna try and feed questions to
them and we'll try and get there the
benefit of their expertise because I
think sometimes they will be able to
frame issues in a way that go beyond the
questions we're asking but then I would
really like to get to the the the
questions that so many of you has and
we'll get through though those as
quickly as possible
Bharath can you talk us through how your
world has looked for the last few weeks
what you've been working on and what's
what's really stood out to you I'm
leading on what from what Professor
David Heyman has just bared with us my
world has also been in a similar
direction and we got busy the moment we
heard about a problem in wuhan hubei
province in China people like myself who
deal with communicable diseases like
these and emerging novel viruses are
always in tune looking out for such
developments and as soon as we knew
about it we were all into action
stations so locally at my University of
Exeter we activated our pandemic
preparedness plans and in addition to
that we have been really busy giving
reassuring scientific measured advice to
our listeners I have been on media
across the board from my local national
and international places just passing on
factual really important factual
scientifically proven evidence rather
than an
the banking myths because there are just
equal number of false media fake news as
you would put it so we've been very busy
since January and we and what I have
found is that the media can be our
friend and through the media I think I
have spoken to so many thousands of
people across the globe giving them
measured scientific evidence brilliant
Barra
thank you very much they've been bunking
the myths and you've been debunking them
and I'm sure that some of those
questions will we'll be able to do do
more of that um Linda can I turn to you
quickly
um I think all the medics have everyone
I know in the infectious disease and
public health world has said for my
entire career that at some point we will
face a pandemic like this even if they
haven't known when and I don't know if
the economists have maybe had to
scramble even more than the the public
health community to respond to this how
is the crisis affecting economists yeah
I think there have certainly been you
know you kind of miss on the lookout for
what the next sort of big crisis pan
down there can be so I think there is
some preparatory work but I think what
makes this Christ is very different is
that the global nature of it and
obviously the you know the medics one
will be able to make a better parallel
before you condemn lists it's very
unusual to have a sudden stop in the
economy in other words you know people
just have they can't go to work they
can't do their normal things they're
working from home firms have to be
closed down for a medical reason so all
of these things mean the economy's in a
really fragile states over the past few
weeks certainly an economist that I know
have been looking at writing advising on
the ways in which government can respond
to make sure that this sudden stopped
this impact doesn't have a longer-term
impact on the economy so supporting
people supporting viable businesses
making sure firstly that the health
system has the resources it needs all of
these things are really key and so for
instance and
last week I know everything feels like
it's been going up a very long time but
it was actually only last Monday when we
had the first assessment of what the
Chancellor had put out in the budget to
help address Cove in nineteen because
the previous week was the budget on the
Wednesday so on the Monday so last
Monday I appeared before the Treasury
Committee in the House of Commons
alongside a panel of economists to
basically to assess the scale of the
response and even at that point we said
the Chancellor has done quite a bit but
it was clear wasn't enough we really
need to try unexpected things new things
like for the very first time the UK
actually giving job retention support to
make sure people do not lose their jobs
so you know and that kind of discussion
and what we've seen in terms of the
helpers self-employed last Friday in the
u case another example of economists
feeding into this policy and I think
globally you can look around the world
very similar things happening as well so
economists sound are busy and some of
them are also do monkey debunking those
myths
yes very I mean I probably will look
what we're gonna do at first of all I'm
gonna I'm gonna focus on David and
Bharat we're gonna talk a bit about the
trajectory of the pandemic and whether
or not we can trust the experts in terms
of the the modeling and all these things
Linda I probably have more questions for
you as an economist than I do I feel
like I have my two certainly said I had
my head around some of the the public
health but I'm the economics I feel like
some people are saying we're inventing
new tools it's amazing this this could
be an incredibly valuable thing for
governments all the stuff we're doing
but also I there are so many concerns
about perverse incentives about people
falling through the cracks and of course
about massive massive numbers of people
being pushed into extreme poverty which
they may struggle to escape so we're
gonna come back to all of those things I
know you don't have all the answers but
to pick your brains but David and Vera
um can I start with you they're been
very different
at least our media has portrayed the the
different responses from different
country's has been quite extreme some
countries Hong Kong Singapore South
Korea seem to have been very effective
at reducing the spread and the death
rate seems to have been very different
David can I start with you you've worked
all over the world were we slow to act
have these other countries responded
better than us and what can we learn
from them well it's clear that the
countries that had SARS outbreaks in the
past were much better prepared than the
rest of the world they learned a lesson
in Hong Kong in Singapore and South
Korea learned a lesson during the
outbreaks of MERS coronavirus just
recently and so these countries are very
well prepared to take care of the surge
of patients in their hospitals and
they've also known that it's very
important that people be reassured that
they can participate not only in
protecting themselves but in protecting
others and so we're seeing that people
in Singapore and in Hong Kong are
wearing a mask if they're coughing or
sneezing to prevent others from being
infected and they're also doing other
things that prevent themselves from
being infected physical distancing
staying away from crowds and washing
their hands a whole series of things so
this is a good base on which these
countries have been able to develop an
outbreak response that identifies
patients isolates those patients and
keeps the economy going at the same time
and um do you have a sense that the
countries that have really really
clamped down on this hard and stop the
spread or facing a very difficult choice
because we know that these measures will
stop it we also know they're
incompatible with a normal normal
functioning of the economy and also
really normal functioning of human life
you know social contact the economy is
not the only thing I'm our Singapore now
facing a very difficult challenge about
when to allow the virus to spread my
sense is this virus isn't going to go
away
and we're not talking about something
like Ebola where we might be able to
eliminate it in a region but instead
we've only been talking about slowing
the virus are they making trouble for
themselves with these very very
effective responses
well what they've done is they've begun
to see that the reproductive number that
is the number of people infected from
each person is gradually increasing and
so they're beginning to relax some of
the measures if they've had in order to
see if that continues or if they can
maintain a low level of transmission and
what they've done is much different than
in European and North American countries
because those countries have learned
from Italy the problems that can occur
if there's a surge of patients that the
hospital system can't cope with so there
are measures to stop the outbreak of
different in Asia because they have a
different goal their goal is not to keep
transmission in a lower level it's to
stop the surge of patients in hospitals
okay lovely and and do you feel like
Western countries in general I know
we've had a lot of internal criticism of
our government but I'm asking you less
to speak to that and more like you know
we could see this coming in January or
we should have been able to possibly
were we too slow to act should we have
been building all these extra
ventilators now should we have been
ordering personal protective equipment
do you feel like we've been slow to act
I feel you're maybe a bit closer to that
that planning can you comment on that
well I think that countries were plan
for we're planning for a pandemic of
influenza and they had stocked up a
certain amount ready for that but no one
expected this pandemic to occur what
happened in January was that China by
clamping down as hard as they did on the
outbreak was able to give the world a
period of time to really prepare some
countries did a better job at preparing
than others in some countries have
chosen a different approach the UK chose
a bottom-up approach at the start to get
the population to understand how they
could work to prevent this outbreak from
exploding whereas other countries
immediately came from a top-down
approach which approach has been more
effective no one will know until the you
know I think the jury's still out
actually okay lovie so so all the all
the armchair pundit
who are saying we'd mess this up and
we've we you know it's all been a total
disaster in terms of our government's
response I my sense is that in fact we
do although everyone is scrambling we
haven't made a total mess of it and and
that's the sense I get you're saying as
well um Bharat can I can I talk to you
about about the feasibility of this
massive testing the sort of the typical
response in public health emergencies
involves massive testing contact tracing
specific quarantine of the people and we
know that it's been happening quite
effectively in countries like Korea and
we don't seem to be doing that now why
have we been so slow on the testing
compared to say China and Korea thank
you and before we go on to that if I may
add to what Professor Haman has just
because I think it is important and I as
a consumer consultant communicable
disease control learnt the basics the
basics the basics are you test you
identify you isolate you contact trace
and the sooner you act the better the
results therefore keeping the lid tight
and tightly controlled is a fundamental
thing that you do in an outbreak
situation therefore this idea of letting
go of testing identifying isolating
contact tracing happened a bit too early
in the United Kingdom and we are still
wondering why did it happen why did you
give up on it too early because in the
early days as you noticed in the report
in China and and in Singapore they
clamped down hard and fast and as a
result you keep the case numbers down
and by keeping case numbers down you
have better control so that's what I
wanted to add to the conversation that
has just followed coming back to the
issue of testing my colleagues and I are
at a bit of a loss with regards to the
United Kingdom which is very very good
in it is a highly developed we have a
lot of biochemical industries in in the
UK as to why we're having hiccups with
regards to testing the PCR testing which
is what I'm interested in because the
PCR testing is what allows me to
identify case or not the antibody tests
that come later they are an afterthought
for me it doesn't help me with my
outbreak control measures
so really the testing that I want is of
the reverse transcriptase PCR so that I
can identify with it just to be clear
just to be clear for anyone listening
the difference is that one test can test
whether or not a person has had the
illness and has made antibodies and
that's that can be very very valuable in
some aspects of the response but unless
that Berra is talking about identifies
the virus itself and so it tells you
whether you were actively infected at
the moment sorry Barrett to interrupt
you I just want to make sure that people
you're interested in you're interested
in knowing who has the virus at the
moment that they have it and I agree and
and and and that it's a complicated test
it can take several hours to do it
requires people with quite expert
training working machines and using
reagents so what's the but what's been
the delay China and Korea were able to
roll this out pretty effectively why
have we been so slow we we do have labs
all over the country as you say that
could be doing PCR yeah and just to add
the PCR test is not that complicated to
do and that's why I feel a little bit of
frustration that it is it is a good test
but it is not that complicated to do and
we can scale up very quickly and I just
have a little bit of disappointment that
if countries like South Korea Singapore
and others can and Germany can ramp up
their testing why we have not been able
to do it I don't know the answer I would
really like that to it go ahead yeah I
mean I think I know I was I was just
wondering if David did know the answer
or at least could have some suggestions
I've spoken to people who've said we're
lazy idiots in this country and I've
spoken to lots of other people who've
said actually although it is a
relatively straightforward bit of
science as you say it's not a pregnancy
test it's not a thing it's not like a
blood glucose test it still does require
reagents and a certain amount of
complexity and time to do it and and and
so in fact the reagents and machines are
in short supply have you got any insight
into into where the where that where the
truth lies between those poles Davids
well you know I think what countries are
doing is the best that they can do based
on their risk assessment and you know I
can't make a judgement as to why the UK
is not testing or why Germany is not
testing or why Korea is testing more all
I can say is that when you do test and
identify patients as Bharat said you can
then make sure that they're properly
isolated and the same is true with the
context of those patients if they're
tested they can be shown to be they can
be infected making speech be isolated as
well and prevent new chains of
transmission with their other tests that
are also important as you said earlier
and that's an antibody test which when
validated will be able to tell whether
people have had infection in the past
and that's the test it's also been
lacking in all countries but it's
rapidly coming online and I believe the
UK said they will have it online within
a couple weeks now I am the outbreak man
and I want to keep case numbers down and
therefore the antibody test is all well
and good however it is the PCR test
which allows me to control my outbreak
and it is very important to know the
difference between the two the antibody
for me is an after the event test it
allows me to say you have been infected
I have got proof of antibodies in you it
is not as as as as accurate a test as
the PCR test is the PCR test also has
its issues but the PCR test allows me to
know whether I need to pull this person
out of circulation or not and that is
very important so I hope we're gonna
come I'm sure there will be there I know
the
there are lots of questions about
testing so I'm going to come on to that
the other thing that we can get to
before the end of the hour is this some
all the kind of controversy the team
about our Oxford scientists saying this
week that the you know everyone's
already infected and the government's
modeling is wrong and we've had lots of
contradictory models coming out of or at
least the reporting has been that the
models are contradictory I think they'll
come up in the question so if I can keep
ask David and Barrett to keep those in
your minds Linda before we throw open to
the audience I'm just interested about
the impact on the economy the the I'm
amazed to still be reading articles that
say you know it seems in the FT I think
there's a headline today this is we do
seem to be at high risk of a depression
I would have thought it was completely
inevitable is that right to give a quote
by great economist Galbraith who said
economic forecasting exists to make
astrology look respectable you know I
think it's the recessionary part of a
business psycho or just you know it'd be
it'd be very very hard to basically to
say that we're not either in recession
or recessionary and most economies
because of this because of the sudden
stop nature it's incredibly disruptive
you know crisis so I think whether or
not it becomes a depression which by the
way there's no there's not an easy
technical definition for depression a
recession is two negative quarters
consecutively when the economy contracts
Ronald Reagan's definition is a
recession is when your neighbor loses
his job the depression is when you lose
your job so we don't have you know I say
that not not you know it's where you sit
depends upon where you stand yeah
exactly so for a lot of people the worry
will feel like is this depression
because they're worried about their jobs
and in countries with they
weak social safety nets that is going to
be a concern so for them it doesn't
really matter the economy as a whole is
recessionary for them it's gonna feel
like a depression so this actually takes
me to the importance of government
policies when demand in the economy from
the private sector dries up like it is
now
the government must step in they have to
firstly try to keep people in employment
and that's what the job retention
schemes are about the one in the UK is
the first time the British government
ever data they didn't do it in the
banking crisis a decade ago but now
they're doing it and you can be
furloughed instead of becoming
unemployed the government will pay 80%
of your wages plus your pension
contribution plus National Insurance
contribution and then the other part is
the employers which are the actual firms
the viable ones have cash flow problems
they also need help and obviously we
need to keep the viable ones afloat and
the gig economy is now very massive
there's a lot of people who fall between
the cracks or hidden self-employment the
benefit system wouldn't really be enough
and so it's not just the UK but the u.s.
is just Congress passed the bill but for
the very first time helps the economy
workers who are gonna get unemployment
benefits the same as employed workers so
if governments can come together provide
cashflow support for businesses relaxed
rules that don't need to be in a crisis
for instance when bankruptcy and most of
all protect people then that prevents
this recessionary shark from being a
deeper longer recession or depression
can I ask him there are a couple of I
think one of the questions that are on
there is on loss of non economist minds
is about the balance between rescuing
people like the kind of people I know
who work in cafes or owned small
businesses or are self employed in the
arts for instance versus bailing out an
airline and helping out the billionaires
um if you're an economist is that an
important question the sort of the
fairness of this response I think it
feels to me like there are
individuals who may fall through the
cracks but lots of large businesses will
be rescued and propped up fairness is
absolutely essential because I think
what you want to make sure is the
responses helping those who most needed
so you can see this in terms of for
instance the self employment measure
that's being put in in the UK has a
cut-off in terms of tradable profits
trading profits because it's trying to
target those who need it now for big
businesses and you know I think the
dilemma is a lot of them are also big
employers now most employers are SMEs
and they will get help but if we think
about the airlines you mentioned or rail
which is effectively being nationalized
in the UK for the next six months you
know these are you know these are
industries companies that we we need to
operate but if they get help it has to
be bespoke and it needs to come with
conditions for instance if you get
support you need to hang on to your
workers you can't use the money to buy
back shares all of these things are
properly imposed to make sure that what
you're doing is preserving employment
and helping them with cash flow and I
think that is absolutely crucial in the
UK they're just squeezed the middle of
firms who are being left out by the
government measures and it's the same
case in a lot of other countries there's
a lot of smaller companies may not have
say an investment grade rating they
can't access the help being offered by
central banks so to me it's specifically
looking out for those who've been left
out of the measures that's got to be the
names priority oh that and getting all
these schemes up and running because of
the delay in getting money to people is
absolutely scary for a lot of people and
southern plan and support won't come in
until June the furloughed workers that
probably money won't come until May
hopefully sooner all of those things I
think must be considered and this is why
there's some talk of being a Czech thing
sent to people you know again the u.s.
is doing this below a certain income
level because it just gets some money
into their pockets and it was done in
the last recession than us in the growth
financial crisis as well as in 2000
one hong kong's done it japan is looking
at doing it and that's why we're getting
cash quickly into people's pockets so
think all of those things have to be
looked at good so we probably have not
heard the last of the the finessing of
the rescue package I've got so many more
questions but migrations are not as
important as the audience's questions so
let's start going and I'm gonna try and
dish these out um kind of as as they
come up and if you can keep your answers
compact and I'll try and um if you don't
mind speakers I'll hassle you all
through it um so that we can get to as
many as possible okay question number
one how long after you've had the virus
should you no longer be contagious
how long you not passing it on to anyone
else Madoka might throw this one to you
my understanding is that seven days
after the time of in signs and symptoms
developing the person can be fairly sure
if they are free of virus even if
they're still in a hospital and in
critical condition the virus should by
that time have been eliminated from the
body although it can stay longer in
those people who are critically ill but
barod is closer to clinical medicine and
i you may want to add something thank
you thank you and my extra bit is I
agree with what Professor Hyman has just
said and I would also like to add that
in some categories of patients patients
who are immune suppressed they may go on
to secrete the viruses for much longer
and then one more thing which we really
need to address and investigate properly
and that is the virus is present in
human feces and we have not really
evaluated properly whether there is no
virus post recovery or is there virus
after recovering from your seven-day
illness so that is something where
people are looking into and because
there is this thing of virus may be
present in human feces important that
you exercise extreme cleanliness after
the event best advice your hands
everybody wash your hair
yes down and then you flush it is a
better practice to undertake thank you
very much Barrett you will have solved
family arguments up and down the UK
possibly all over the world about
whether the toilet seat goes up or down
the toilet seat goes down you should
wash your hands and the government
advice is that after seven days and I
think your exception for immune immune
suppressed people is it's really
important Barack but yes for instance I
have just I had a fever I had a cough
I've self quarantine for seven days
today is my first day out and I'm still
coughing I feel guilty to cough in the
supermarket but I hope that I'm not
infecting anybody else next question how
are corona patients registered and who
is collecting these numbers are we are
we in fact kind of keeping a database of
Corona BP and are we treating them
differently to anyone else here we are
okay yes yeah the answer is simple which
it has become an officially notification
of infectious diseases it's a statutory
requirement for any clinician it doesn't
have to be a doctor it can be any
attending clinician so it can be a nurse
etc if they suspect on clinical grounds
that this is a corona virus then they
have to statutorily that means by law
let us know and and the collecting body
is public health England for England
there are similar bodies in Scotland
Northern Ireland and Wales perfect so we
are we are gathering the data yes the
only reported cases of coronavirus
infection globally to the World Health
Organization are those that are
confirmed so many times countries are
not looking for the virus in those who
are less seriously ill and they don't
report those cases what's a good
indicator though of what's going on
unfortunately is the mortality because
if you do have increasing mortality you
know that you probably do have in
addition increasing patients even though
the reporting may not be accurate
because the reporting is only good as
good as the as is the testing
um your views on vaccines several people
asking about this will a vaccine be made
within a year do you think I know that
this is a nightmare to ask but some bars
I don't think so this is not an easy
thing to make and whilst we have a lot
of hope on vaccines one year lucky hid
is an extremely lucky hit there is a lot
of processes to go through we need to
find a candidate protein we need to find
a protein or a item from the virus that
is antigenic safe and produces long
lasting immunity so there are several
hurdles here and and I'm sitting on the
fence by saying I don't think we will
have a vaccine in the near future David
you're you're nodding gloomily yes you
know the process of developing a vaccine
depends first on developing the vaccine
as abroad said then testing it in
animals to see if it's effective and
safe and animals and then going on to
humans and that's a long process
fortunately recently it has been
identified that there is a monkey that
can be infected a macaque can be
infected like humans and be a model for
testing vaccines but it is a long
process and there will be short cuts
made the regulatory agencies are trying
to accommodate these but there will be
no compromise on safety and on
effectiveness and on the duration of
immunity that's lovely thank you very
much okay do we know how long the virus
can stay active or alive or infectious
on different surfaces particularly
things like food packaging if I go to
the supermarket I buy a can of milk and
summer a can of milk a bottle of milk
whatever milk comes in and I have and
someone's coughed on the hand and
touched it and then I touch it how long
is it infectious before four and what
can we do about that it's how long is a
piece of string a question and I would
like people to stop focusing on how long
does it survive on certain surfaces you
know so far it's for me to say that on
hard surfaces plastics especially it
lasts a lot longer so if you have a nine
warm humid environment and it's a
plastic surface it may last a lot longer
whereas if it is on a drying surface it
may last shorter time because it dries
out desiccates and dies but the
important message is this think about it
as every surface every item where humans
congregate is infected infectious and a
risk hazard and if you treat it that way
you are not making the mistake of saying
this surface is safe this surface is not
safe and you know you will make mistakes
if you go along that pathway so it's
better to consider all surfaces unsafe
wash your hands frequently and that
would be a much better strategy I love
it that's that's that's brilliant and I
think that's much easier for people to
manage that um is there proof I'm well
aware that we've got sort of two -
medics and I'm an economist
I'm Linda there are some questions
coming your way so nobody nobody worry
for Linda getting boredom but there's a
couple of these they're proof once once
you've got the virus um is there do we
believe that that will confer immunity
and if so for how long we don't know um
we we all we know is that you've got
evidence of immunity against the corona
virus yeah but we don't know if this
immunity is long lasting permanent
robust can be reactivated all those are
extra hurdles to face I'm sure professor
havens got some extra bits to add to
what I've just said immunity for other
corona viruses that cause the common
cold does not last a very long time in
fact you can never come in cold from a
corona virus this year and you can have
that same virus infect you and cause a
cold next year so this the hope is that
this virus because it's a new virus in
humans might in fact cause greater
stronger immunity but nobody knows for
sure and that's the problem with vaccine
development as as as well
will a vaccine provide the immunity as
where I said it will protect us in the
long term and Linda I think people often
feel that economists can be a bit
hard-hearted but I think economists
hearing that and saying this virus isn't
going to go away it is terribly
infectious and it may even not confer
very long-lasting immunity and and so we
we are facing this situation where we're
going to have to deal with it for a long
period of time this then the economists
start to feel rather desperate about
getting people back to work how do you
balance those how do you balance those
concerns Linda I think the priority has
to keep people staying and I think this
is something that pretty much all
countries have you know certainly and
agree to or agree on I think one of the
things to stress is until there is a
vaccine and obviously the and the
scientists will know this much better it
may well be we have to get used to some
you know some degree of social
distancing measures remote working
becoming your more regular feature until
we're sure that the crisis the medical
crisis is under control so I think for
the Economist that's something that
quite a few are certainly aware of I
don't think there's any expectation
somehow that you know we'll get back to
normal
normal as in I guess be able to leave
our homes you know very quickly until
that is the case yeah lovely look I'm so
sorry everybody I have not been
mentioning the names of the people who
are asking such actual aggressions I'm
sorry about that I can now I can now see
where your names are so I will start
mentioning but apologies for that the
the latest data from gulf dot uk' shows
a lower number of respiratory deaths for
the week do we know why that the deaths
might be might be going down is this a
reason to be optimistic or is this just
variation in the in the data and that's
from an bird what is this for the United
Kingdom we are referring to yeah yeah
look
data takes time to catch up and remember
we are in the early exponential rise
phase of this outbreak so this is two
early days for us to sit back and say
it's looking good or bad we need to
brace ourselves and the reason why we
need to brace ourselves is we are in the
exponential rising phase of this
outbreak whatever the numbers that we
have at the moment they're subject to
revision but what is quite clear is we
are in the upward trend so therefore
brace ourselves for cases people needing
intensive care and respiratory support
it's coming and that's also the picture
globally des continued to rise they may
be decreasing temporarily in some
countries a lag of reporting or whatever
but deaths in general are increasing
which shows as where I said that this
epidemic is still increasing in size
there's a lovely question here from
Jonathan Sealy which I think it's very
interesting governments and all kinds of
agencies are keen to manage the flow of
information very carefully and Jonathan
wants to know what are we not being told
brackets for fear of causing panic
my sense is probably probably not a huge
amount and that the apparent
transparency is probably real is is that
the case clearly there may be emerging
plans that they don't want to they don't
want to leak too early but are we being
told that everything or is there are
there other secret secret bits of bad
news you think that maybe and withheld
from the population yeah but zan do you
know that what you don't know you don't
know you I suppose I would say you've
sat in you've sat in in in you you um
the three of you in different ways um
but but but but you and David in terms
of epidemic management have sat in the
room and been privy to things that not
everyone else is aware of is there a
sense of saying look we have to we have
to manage this message very carefully or
is it do you feel like we are likely to
be being told what's happening I I know
that you're not prepared to leak
anything but is the transparency real um
look
if I may go first if you like myself
from universities are known as
troublemakers and it is good to have
that badge because we like to challenge
question and question again and hold
people to account and we're not doing it
because we enjoy doing it but because we
want real science to be practiced and we
want to contribute to the science
decisions that the government may be
taking and therefore my colleagues and I
have been pressing for what evidence are
you looking at and finally sage has
published the series of documents that
it is using as a reference material
which is a good thing because that's
good transparency and we would like to
contribute but contribute from outside
and say good things when good things are
going on and add to come on you could do
this as well so you know that's where we
are operating for we're working together
and the government may see us as an
irritant but we are not an irritant we
want to make things better okay good
good no that's that's reassuring David
do you have a sense that we're being
reasonably but reasonably but informed I
think it's been globally quite
interesting to see how people have
shared data either in medical journals
where they're put in front of the de
Waal or or just by informally sharing
and sharing with wh Oh in fact the
Chinese were not at all transparent as
you know the stars outbreak they didn't
watch the reporting they finally did
report it when they were accused
publicly of putting the rest of the
world at risk and the Chinese today are
reporting freely as are other countries
now of course this is government
reporting and there may be things that
the government doesn't report as in all
countries but at least there's been
enough reported for a good understanding
of the virus and what's going on
worldwide well that's reassuring it yeah
yeah no I agree with you and Linda I
know this is not quite a question for
this isn't quite economics but I feel
like every bit of policy had a bit
conspiracy behind it when the pubs
weren't closed all the pictures of Boris
with
the owner of Weatherspoon's were
circulated when the contract for the
ventilators given to Dyson all the
pictures and consent or emps which James
Dyson was circulated in fact is is that
how the Chancellor is making economic
policy or is it is it driven by them a
group of them academics and other monks
and nerds and good people I actually
think it is the latter I think there's
been a real an effort to get input so I
mentioned this how much has happened
over the last you know seven to ten days
in this country and I think you know the
instances that you mentioned is always
going to be a bit of that but I think
there you know the thrust of the
policies which in this country have been
really extraordinary in economic terms
these had being the right ways to
approach it and I would I would hope
that the next phase of it would look
similar I just don't think there's any
sense I'm not getting any sense that
this is a time to be doing anything
other than following expert advice and
expert guidance provided the experts can
agree so on this one the economies are
closer together for once and it's
actually the medical community that
might be a little bit when you mentioned
the officers versus Imperial study
earlier well we can that we're gonna get
that Linda while I'm on you I'm Hilary
Pearson wants to know why don't the
major supermarkets form a cartel to
reduce their prices should we be
allowing cartels so the government is
allowing cartels right now so Hillary
you know something okay that's that's
really interesting with us that's
something I'm gonna I'm just gonna
oh sorry yelling - go ahead miss
Leighton they're both allowing cartels
to help Rick keep supplies bulk
purchases and keep pricing down the CMA
the competition's markets Authority has
also formed a coded ninety task force to
prevent price gouging because the other
side of the cartel is together
good kind of cartel that's what we want
the Suzy Suzy Aird wants to know some
people wear face masks when they go out
others don't
what do you what do you advise so look
in the United Kingdom Western nations
we're not used to wearing masks and if
you put on this mask and you're fiddling
forever with your getting it right and
you're having a lot of excess activity
around your nose and mouth you may in
error introduce infection that way
through that mask furthermore the mosque
gets lovely and moist very very quickly
and when it gets lovely and moist it is
not going to actually hold back viruses
that wish to find their way to you and
it may give you a false sense of
security and if you just think about it
it's a nanometer all right it's a tiny
tiny little speck and the pores on the
mosque are not necessarily good barriers
one more thing the mosques are really
good in a clinical setting so where you
have the COFF the person is actually ill
then they're that mosque is a very good
idea and similarly for the clinician to
put on a fresh mosque every time they
see a patient that's also a good idea
but I'm sure David got it
David yeah we just added we had a really
lively discussion today at a World
Health Organization meeting again by
internet and at that discussion there
were the Asian groups and the European
groups were talking about the wearing of
masks and the Asians concluded that
number one they always wear a mask when
they're sick when they're coughing to
prevent others from getting sick by
getting droplets when they cough or
sneeze and that they should be worn then
as Bharat said not only by patients in
the hospital they'll be in the community
while at the same time wearing masks
feeling
checking yourself is not thought to be
effective yet it's a confidence-building
measure for some people and Hong Kong
for example has promoted it whereas
Singapore has not so it all depends on
what countries feel that their cultures
are more likely to be able to accept and
which will build confidence in those
people there's also temperature changing
taking every time you enter a public
building or enter a classroom in any
part of Asia that isn't done in Europe
but it's a confidence building that
they're measure that they use in Asia to
let people know that they're surrounded
by people who don't have a fever
so there are merit various things that
can be done but maths has a protection
against infection as where I said are
not known to be effective okay that's
that's lovely so if you're um I I think
I think that should answer that answer
the question so don't panic if you see
people at people outside with masks but
there is a role for masks as well how
Germany's mortality rate seems to be
lower than everywhere else and yet my
understanding is the there is not very
much mutation that doesn't seem to be a
German strain now I don't know if
there's viral epigenetics that are maybe
important to measure that that just the
simple genomics don't tell you but David
if you've got any idea why M&E seems to
be an outlier in Europe well first it's
important to know that the virus is
fairly stable there are over 600
specimens in a database called yes aid
which come from around the world and
they've shown slight what we call drift
slight mutations but nothing major and
there's been no way of correlating that
at all with the virulence of the
organism or its transmissibility so I
think the German theory or the theory
that Germany is having less mortality
because they have a different virus is
wrong the real answer is that Germany
knows how to manage its patients and
hasn't had a an excess of patients that
have overwhelmed as health systems the
UK is doing quite well also in managing
patients as are as are many other
countries but what happened in Italy was
a mess
of infection at the same time of a group
of elderly people and elderly people are
a greater risk of mortality and in
addition the hospitals were overwhelmed
and all those people
bubbly Barra and anything to add on that
brat no I totally agree with Professor
Hyman that you know there is no wireless
one and virus two we will get drifts but
it's the same bug I'm afraid brilliant
um ease there's a few questions here I'm
Linda Reis Johansson is asking but
there'll be other people worried about
it if they've got mild asthma does that
make you vulnerable but the guidelines
when I looked on the public health
England website I felt the guidelines
for a little a little big on this they
talked about chronic health conditions
um if someone has mild asthma was huge
numbers of people do um do they consider
themselves vulnerable should they behave
differently to other people so look I'm
happy to take that question I look at it
as two independent events you have
asthma and you may you may not get
infected with coronavirus and just
because you've got infected but the
corona virus doesn't mean it's going to
necessarily make your asthma worse
because most asthma is allergen caused
it's caused by things like pollen that
you're sensitive to smoke dust pollution
that sort of thing what we have to be
aware of nevertheless is a asthmatic may
be taking steroids to keep that that
asthma under control and by virtue of
taking those steroids you may be
slightly very very marginally immune
suppressed and therefore you if you were
to get infected by the corona virus the
corona virus infection may be a little
bit greater in the asthmatic but I think
the best way to deal with this is to say
look we don't know there are two
independent events hmm lovely um Edward
Edmund Jankowski has invoked President
Trump saying his president shall correct
a query whether there was
directions on the economy may cause more
damage than the virus I mean President
Trump has a kind of snake-like instinct
for what people want to hear and his
ratings are doing very well at the
moment despite what I think people on
the outside might regard us as not
brilliant management in in in many
aspects of the US response Linda can I
put that to you is how are we going to
make that calculation I know you've
already addressed a little bit already
but he is raising a question in in a
slightly unpleasant way that that it
must be on lots and lots of people's
minds I think that the restrictions on
the economy are really to make sure that
we control and help the health side of
the population and that will have a
negative economic impact so whether or
not it has a longer-term impact
depends on how government's address what
you know are the restrictive effects so
in other words if people have to work
from home they can worry about their
income they're not going to buy as much
and it's all the things that we
discussed you've got to help people stay
and work you've got to replace income
you've got to help businesses those
things come into effect there's
something which is very short and sharp
today may not necessarily have a
longer-term impact what we know from
economic studies and economic history is
that if you do not help people then they
become unemployed and detached from the
labor market
it's called hysteresis and that's how
you turn a short term ira sharp downturn
into having an impact on the entire
potential of the economy in the years
ahead so that's probably I think why the
government response is so keen I'm so
good - what must focus on I can see your
hand brought but I think I think what
you're saying is really really just just
to make sure that we've understood it
you're saying there's a bit of a false
dichotomy there but actually it is
possible to preserve the economy and and
do things to strengthen it even as we
fight the disease and it is not simply a
balance of one thing in another
embarrass Ari I didn't mean to interrupt
you know Linda I hear you I hear you
loud and clear
I
I'm very concerned about America and its
approach to infection control I did a
little bit of training at the Centers
for Disease Control in Atlanta Georgia
America there are some very clever very
nice people at the CDC in Atlanta and
there have been sidelined and as a
result today we noticed that America has
the greatest number of cases greater
than China its population is much less
than that of China that is a huge red
flag this is something seriously wrong
in the United States of America you must
do something about it because innocent
Americans will die this is not right
yeah I totally agree well turd to pick
up on that idea this question from Mark
Du Bois I don't know if it is the mark
Du Bois who used to head up MSF UK but
if it is hello and if it's not still
hello mark the question is when talk
about the trade-offs between lives and
prosperity you seem to be talking about
the national level but it causes a
global question does anyone have any
thoughts about the impact of the virus
pandemic in the poorest places in the
world South Sudan Central African
Republic and so on and so on I think
it's so we are so caught up in our
immediate surroundings in some cases our
immediate neighborhoods burden but of
course there are people in the world who
are even more vulnerable than us can you
um can you I'd like everyone to talk on
that can I just go through you one at a
time starting with you David yeah you
know we don't yet understand in many
developing countries what the full
impact of this virus will be especially
in sub-saharan Africa where the
population is much younger overall than
it is in Europe so ain't the hopes are
that this virus won't be so damaging to
certain population groups in certain
parts of the world but it is true that
any pressure on the economy and any
pressure on people who live from hand to
mouth will cause problems not only in
the short term but in the long term
Bharat's
um my concerns are and I have
articulated this many times is if we
have runaway uncontrolled infection in
the poorer countries what happens is you
have a
amplification of number of cases and
hence number of viruses and that
amplification makes that virus more
persistent and it will come to bite the
richer countries therefore my advice has
always been whilst you are paying money
to control the infection in your country
the Western nations the Western nations
must support the w-h-o to also control
the infection in the poorer nations
because if you don't it will come back
to also harm us a second third wave yeah
yeah apart from the moral issues there
is a pragmatic case heading there as
well I agree
and Linda clearly there is am a threat
to to low-income countries and many
people around the world not just in
terms of the virus but also that they
are at the end of a they are the final
step and a collapsing economy where they
they are the people whose jobs and
livelihoods may evaporate completely
what how should we be responding
globally to that some issues extending
credit to countries that need it who are
using it to strengthen their health
systems protect people and support firms
there's already efforts between the IMF
and the World Bank to make this money
immediately available and rich countries
should forgive or at least put a
moratorium on that repayment from these
countries because obviously a lot of
developing countries are also indebted
to the richer countries so in other
words we should be doing everything
possible both for moral reasons and also
some of the practical ones because
emerging economies tend to have weaker
comprehensive health systems it's
already been mentioned so the chances of
the impact having a human cost as is
greater in some of those countries then
then it should be unless there is help
and I think also if you look at the
economic data whatever people investors
businesses start to pull back the amount
of money that's actually left developing
countries if you imagine a graph in the
global financial crisis money flowed out
pretty steeply in this crisis the chart
looks like this it's a complete moving
out and this is money that's needed to
help these
trees with their financing what their
businesses so absolutely the global
response has to be there on the medical
front and certainly the economic front
because the one thing we have learned I
think is that the world is very
connected and if we want the global
economy to recover we have to make sure
all the parts of it are being supported
so that we can come out of this and not
have lasting damage um today the Prime
Minister this is a question from
Marbella Spain as karate' and forgive me
if I'm pronouncing it badly as someone
whose name is also difficult to
pronounce I feel like I get a free pass
on on bad pronunciation but there we go
the the Prime Minister the chief medical
officer and the health secretary have
all been confirmed as having covered 19
- day how can the public be assured that
the government is definitely in control
of this pandemic how can we maintain
confidence in our experts and our
political leaders when they can't even
stop themselves getting it can you I
actually have an answer to that as well
but I'm more interested in hearing from
the panel again David can I start with
you and what's your was your response to
that well certainly viruses don't select
any one person to infect and what's
happening is that there is transmission
in the community that we don't
understand and these people have
certainly been in contact with people
who were infected and they didn't know
they were in contact with those people
either because those people didn't know
themselves or because they weren't being
honest and as a result they've become
infected we can only hope that this
infection will not be a serious
infection in them or really in any one
health parrot I think professor Heyman
has made a very very important point
even without realizing it and that is he
probably did realize it take it as read
he said this infection is transmitting
ways we don't fully understand and that
is really important because we know what
we know but we also must have our minds
open to we don't know what we don't know
and there
keep that mind open that there may be
other modes of transmission yeah it's
very solvent as a scientist so with
respect to ministers and prime ministers
getting infected as Professor Haman has
said a wireless doesn't look for whom it
infects everyone because no one has got
immunity to it what has the yes dome in
the UK will be this how is it possible
for Prince Charles the Prime Minister
and other members of government to have
the test which is not available to
healthcare workers and other people in
the community this will raise a huge
storm for your political pundits your
sociologists to answer we don't have to
do the storm now I agree there was an
interesting interesting there yes yes I
guess the other thing it seems important
to me to say is that and and you to
correct me if I'm wrong about this I'm
sure if I'm wrong you must tell me but
we are trying to slow this virus down
we're not we don't believe that we can
stop it and so um anyone who gets it we
are all there is an inevitable spread of
this and so the idea that anyone in
government would believe that they were
taking measures to completely prevent
the possibility of them catching the
virus that would effectively be wrong
and counter to government advice that we
are we have to slow it but stopping it
is impossible and so I haven't spent
time with Matt Hancock backstage after
question time he is well aware of the
advice of the handwashing advice they
have all been and having been into the
Department of Health and Social Care
they're all doing it they're all doing
their best but they are doing what the
rest of us do and also try to live their
lives is that a reasonable way of
thinking about it that in fact then
catching it is not it's not clearly we
must be concerned for them as humans who
are ill but on them catching it is not a
disaster and it's not a failure of
policy is that a reasonable way of
thinking about it yes I know what the
presentation is very important and you
to get the messages right in the right
order so to use expressions like I'm out
there to get hurt immunity by infection
has upset a lot of people because that
is what biologically inevitably happens
but the presentation could be better in
that we say in the process of time
people will eventually encounter the
virus and eventually recover from it etc
in that way so so the the the way the
herd immunity concept was introduced
upset a lot of people but it is
otherwise inevitable that the normal
course of infections like the corona
virus which is quite infectious it will
find most of us and in fact us over a
period of time what we want to do is get
infected in small a loquats
if we are going to because that allows
the healthcare system to be able to
manage smaller numbers because if you
have 10,000 people suddenly presenting
for treatment we can't do it David and
anything to add on that or you are you
happy with that level of nuance I would
just say that we've had corona viruses
in the past there have certainly come
two populations in the same way and
they've caught they cause the common
cold today
they didn't spread with the speed that
this virus spread they may have been
very very learn at the start but they
learn how to adapt to human populations
and they're now circulating in all
populations so this is not a new type of
event it's just a globalized event that
has occurred very rapidly and we need
now to to do one thing more than just
try to protect ourselves we need to
really try to protect the elderly those
who have comorbidities in particular and
that's why I think the governments in
all countries are concerned about the
nursing homes and the homes for the
elderly making sure that they are also
as secure as can be against this virus
lovely I have a we're very close to
wrapping up I have sort of one more
question for the medics and one one for
you Linda um is there in the creation of
so many enormous lis
in giving access to very large
quantities of money very rapidly in the
creation of so many new schemes there's
the possibility for perverse incentives
and there's also the possibility for
profiteering I think uh how concerned
should we be about that an example I
would give you as a friend of mine runs
a small company in London and said he
will very rapidly go bust and he will be
snapped up by endless numbers of venture
capital people who know they can get an
absolute bargain on lots of little
companies now they've got full war
chests and they perfected their their
perfecting techniques they developed in
2008 so should we worry about
profiteering and and perverse incentives
with the new range of measures which
which can't have been thought through as
well as they might I think that send the
CM a task force that I mentioned before
I think is going to it is actually
intended to try and stop some of that
now the case of your them that you just
mentioned that's very difficult to to
intervene but if there was enough cash
support for that company then perhaps it
just keeps them viable for a bit longer
now in general one of the reasons why
for instance is self-employed measure in
the UK was designed the way it was with
an income threshold and excludes people
who are basically owner directors or
companies it's because they were worried
about fraud now this is very difficult
because obviously a balance has to be
struck you want to make sure that
overall the system works for as many
people as possible but I think the thing
I would probably say at this point is
even if you do end up with some cases of
fraud it would almost be better to err
on the side of helping as many people as
possible and certainly not worry too
much about some of the terms you you
tend to hear about like moral hazard or
you know incentives because it is a
crisis it is an absolute economic crisis
as well as human crisis and the schemes
that have been designed have been done
quickly and yes there's going to be
problems with those but I would say the
biggest problem with all of these
schemes is the speed of getting money
to people and that's the complete
function of the fact that HMRC has never
had to contact self-employed people to
offer them money it is a nice thought by
the way they would do that and you know
with the job retention scheme all of
these things so I think to me that's the
challenge of a quickly designed scheme
there will be flaws but I hope we
learned from it and would be better
prepared and if social safety nets get
strengthened after this that's no bad
thing so we'd have better measures in
place for the next time there's a
pandemic and the next time there's a
crisis thank you so much Linda a final
question - David and Bharat
this is from Neil Wallace and it will be
on many people's minds a recent
well-publicized
Oxford University study said that up
half the UK population may already have
contracted cope at 19 is it conceivable
that such large numbers have already
been affected under the radar is herd
immunity closer than we think if not
what are the speaker's think is the
likely current level of infection in the
population and I guess I would all yes
in fact I won't add any more to that
yeah what what do you think about that
study and what do you think about the
current level of infection in the
population and barak can I start with
you and then we'll come to David so I I
think 50 percent at this early phase is
a little bit over the top
I wouldn't expect 50 percent of a 65 70
million part but a number of population
to already have been infected so I don't
think so the trouble is because we're
not testing and we haven't got the
antibody tests it's difficult for us to
tell us with some degree of accuracy
where we stand so but inevitably with
passage of times if you ask me in say a
year's time has 50% of the population
encountered the virus I might say yes at
this point in time I am a bit doubtful
David yeah you know this is
epidemiological modelling and modelling
is based on what we know today and what
can be assumed from what's learned in
other
countries and so the modelers use this
information in their models and they
give both a maximum and a minimum number
of cases or infections that could have
occurred what happens as many times the
headline grabs the maximum and forgets
to talk about the minimum and then
people get very concerned and very
worried I'm not saying that this model
isn't accurate I'm just saying that it's
a model and models are refined on a
regular basis as more information comes
in so whether or not the population is
infected and 50% is not clear at this
point in time but what's clear is that
we really don't yet know the full
destiny of this virus will this virus
hang around in human populations or will
it disappear but hopefully is it it
would disappear eventually it's less and
less likely that will occur but the
question is how and to what extent will
it continue to transmit in the future
and it's destiny as with all new and
emerging infections is not yet fully
understood fantastic look can I say it
to all three of you I know you are
immensely busy at the moment I'm
enormously grateful on behalf of our
audience for all your your your brain
power in your wisdom being brought to
bear on those questions to the audience
I would say thank you so much for your
energy and your enthusiasm and all your
wonderful questions I'm sorry that we
didn't get to all of them but I feel
like we've got a good range of things I
feel at least for me that I have come
away I'm reassured that there are
probably not very big secret
conspiracies going on that we don't know
about that the government does know what
it's doing and that anyone who is fully
condemning them and saying that we're
we're completely mad has not understood
the variety of effective responses that
are possible and indeed economic
responses as well and Linda's
reassurance that again the Chancellor
will be iterating and trying to figure
out how to stop people falling through
the cracks so I hope this has left you
reassured with some good public health
advice and finally I would say I think
all four of us and intelligent squared
would wish the the Prime Minister the
health secretary and the chief medical
officer wish them all well and of course
we are all thinking of the families who
are grieving for people who who have
died in this epidemic all over the world
and of course all the health care staff
who are doing their best to prevent that
happening
so and thank you very very much and stay
in touch with us and and yes good luck
and take care and look after yourselves
I just wanted to reiterate our big
thanks to the panelists we've received
so many chats from the audience both on
Twitter and in audience chat saying they
were pretty month with the conversation
and insight given to us tonight
we had over 380 people in our audience
this evening and there are hundred
questions given to us it was absolutely
amazing we try to get through them as as
quick as possible
sorry if we couldn't get to answer yours
but do please keep an eye on our Twitter
page and we'll hoped upon a similar
event like this again in the future we
would really love to know what you
thought of this event so will be shortly
sending you an email with a feedback
survey if you could take a moment to
fill it out we'd be most grateful and
finally just a brief message to say that
we've been contacted by a number of
organizations both large and small who
are looking to recreate what we've
delivered here this evening many
businesses are having to adapt very
quickly to the coronavirus situation and
if you work for a company and might be
interested in how intelligence squared
could help you with your digital events
please email us at solutions at
intelligence squared com to find out
more you can check out our website at
intelligence squared comm just click on
the solutions tab and you'll find out
more information and how to get in touch
with us thanks again to our panel have a
lovely evening to our audience and we
hope to see you again very soon
you